The printing press was incredibly revolutionary in all sorts of ways.
Nobody talks about like that 50-75 year period when the printing press first came about and
it was just like, madness, and revolution, and insanity, and all sorts of crazy things happened.
And it took awhile for society to sort of
come to terms with the fact that like, okay,
the monopoly that there used to be on printing,
is now gone.
And I think we're going through something
of the same thing right now.
Following last week’s attack on the US
Capitol by a pro-Trump mob, Twitter permanently
banned the president of the United States
from its platform, and Facebook and YouTube
suspended his accounts.
Meanwhile Parler, which marketed itself as
a more open alternative to Twitter, was booted
from the Apple and Google app stores, and
Amazon Web Services evicted the company from
its cloud computing platform.
Is the great deplatforming of 2021 a threat
to free speech?
Or should we “think of Twitter as a Christian
bakery and Trump as a gay wedding cake,”
as one user of the platform quipped, meaning
that nobody should be able to force a private company
to do business with someone it disagrees with?
Enter Mike Masnick, the 46-year-old entrepreneur
and analyst behind the influential website,
Techdirt, and the digital think tank, the Copia
Institute.
Where others are constantly talking about
how to restrict and regulate the internet
and tech giants to conform to one ideological
vision or another, Masnick champions protocols
and practices that he thinks would lead to
a more decentralized internet and culture,
including expanding Section 230, widespread
encryption, and tools that give end users,
rather than political and cultural commissars, even more power to control what we say
and see online.
Reason spoke with Masnick about what current
debates over social media get drastically wrong,
how free speech is simultaneously empowered and imperiled by politicians here and abroad,
and why a more-decentralized internet
is not just possible but preferable
to what we have now.
Mike Masnick, thanks for talking to Reason.
Yeah, thanks for having me.
Alright, we're going to talk about Section
230.
We're going to talk about deplatforming, replatforming,
unplatforming, and eventually
we're going to get to talk about your fantastic 2019 essay
for the Knight Foundation,
"Protocols, Not Platforms,"
which is about getting to a decentralized or a more decentralized internet.
But first, let me start off with something
that you wrote recently after—you know,
you know I say recently, last week seems like a year
ago, you know, and I don't know, you know,
like 2010 seems like a thousand years ago.
But you wrote last week, I guess I think on
Friday or something, when Trump had been kicked off
at this point of Facebook and of Twitter, you wrote, Trump is perhaps the perfect example
of why demanding clear rules on social media
and how they moderate is stupid.
What do you mean by that?
Yeah, I mean, it's you know, there's a lot of context that goes into that and it's part of a larger discussion.
But I think, you know, almost everybody who is coming at this debate with solutions that say
this is right, this is wrong, or anything
along those lines generally hasn't thought
these issues through.
And hasn't realized not that these decisions are difficult, but that  they are impossible.
And this is something that I've sort of tried to drive home through various conversations that I've had,
that, you know, for people who
have to make moderation decisions.
They have a bunch of choices in front of them, including do nothing.
And all those choices are bad.
All those choices have consequences.
And so there is no right answer.
And I think that a lot of people and this is across the political spectrum, in all sorts of different ways,
and with all sorts of different backgrounds, people think that there is a sort of correct way to do it,
whether that's nothing—like if we get the the algorithm right, you know,
and we won't say the formula, but the algorithm correct,
we just have to put it into, you know, inserted into the internet
and then everything will be ok.
It gets beyond that, right? There's certainly a lot of that.